hey guys it's Justine and today I'm here
with John alright welcome to my office
to my channel I'm pretty excited to be
here I've been watching I'm gonna sound
weird but watch it because for a long
time some I'll make internally and with
right outside I'm like I'm cool well I
also didn't even really look we actually
never had met until which is weird like
I watch your videos or always chatting
on Twitter and stuff like that so here
we are we did a video on his channel
I'll put a link in the description and
annotation wherever those happen to be
today for YouTube we did a little chat
about WTC predictions yes make sure you
guys go check that out some big
surprises I think one of the things that
we're talking about if both of us it was
on our wish list was a bezel list iPad
we talked about a lot of other things
but we won't go over all of those again
because we were chatting for a very long
time but a lot of yes that's iPad I
would use it I would make it like an
iPhone just big I mean this is the iPad
pro this is the first one and this thing
is massive like this is crazy
it is like head size but I usually use
this floor is like a this little gym
area set up in my house like I use this
to watch like workout videos cuz it's
it's huge and you can move it around
imagine how much bigger the screen would
be in the same size package yeah and
then you get face ID in there one of the
complaints that somebody did send me on
Twitter is I said how are we gonna hold
it if it's better list you're gonna kind
of start like hitting things on the side
and you're not gonna have a place to
hold it I figure it out
I mean you figure it out on here yeah
totally sighs like they're gonna promise
off they feel like there could be a
software thing - yeah finger rejection
on the sides they make it still it so
make that work we'll get a couple of
these concepts that I found on Google
really I do go to bed with iPad well
look at that it looks good it looks so
good iOS looking at like the way that
looks is like the weakest part of the
whole package but the hardware looks how
far away those icons are you can think
you can fit probably like 40 bottom or
you can double the icons but that's the
direction I think the iPad is is going
yeah it's more of a computer tool and
being able have more screen real estate
gives you more ability to do more stuff
there's actually no notch on that on
this specific one so that it's gotta be
no no not unless they solve the notch on
the iPad first cuz everyone real estate
well this is what I mean it isn't all
the way to the edge either so there is a
little bit of space so I think that
actually kind of looks
good it looks good to put the sensors up
top that face ID and everybody's
everybody happy and still hold it that
would be awesome look at this I mean
that might as well be a pressure from
like couple months from now
oh my guys this is beautiful these
renders were actually done by sea
concept creator you can check him out on
Twitter and here on YouTube he makes a
really amazing concept art so would you
if you got that would it change the way
you use and I felt like would you
actually use it use it more regularly if
that's what it looked like I think and
if it was a little bit smaller and
lighter with updated iOS and more
functionality it might be something that
I could use more split-screen what
screen would be huge the iPad is the
perfect test area for new iOS features
yeah more real estate it's more
forgiving
so maybe iOS 12 done something new for
iPad that will make its way to the next
I got home to wonder if they'll announce
a new iPad pencil I've had pencil oh my
gosh Abra pencil if you choose the
cheaper one oh yeah the Crayola man but
you can only buy it if you have like an
education discount or something like
that yeah a student I think about I need
to find a student any students out there
I need to get the crayon this is the
perfect time this is an unplanned I was
gonna do an unboxing of it but this is
this is better
you have the crane no do you want to you
can open
yeah I've opened the pencil what is it
it's a special pencil that's really oh
is it a skin it's the D brand
pencil skin okay that's awesome amazing
okay is that we'll see this wasn't
something that I could justify making an
entire video about but of course I am I
just seen so yeah it's probably quite
easily justifiable oh yeah this is a
perfect opportunity it looks really good
no it's awesome it does look really cool
alright be brand I'll see you
I love deer it I think they're great and
I love their Twitter because they're so
sassy oh they are everybody and I'm like
man you are what I want to be but I'm
not that's cool
so whoa this is okay this video is
getting super crazy because Jon also
brought over a few gadgets now my
original idea was I bought this 1997
really nice can
in Macworld and I thought we could react
to it I shipped it to my old address so
I don't have it so instead you brought
over some gadgets I brought surprise and
you saw one of them but you've not seen
everything no there's a box over there
and I see things I see beige old school
Apple tech we had it in my house growing
up apples how I got my start so I
brought so many Apple products that I
don't think a lot of people have seen
because they are older let's start on
the portable side I would like you to
meet a working Macintosh PowerBook 1e
amazing so this was I mean it still has
like my name on it this is I remember
writing papers on this I'm gonna turn it
on for you it's got a it works too no
I've got some surprises on here I have
not changed it this has not been touched
and probably probably fifteen years or
more if no one's came out so I was doing
a little bit of research about these
because I was also looking to get one
what does this have like eight megabytes
of RAM mm-hmm yeah I think so and that
was like the big deal you'd remember the
little smiley Apple guy welcome to
Macintosh you have the RAM tumbler
installed on the nerd back then no way
fun working and functional so we could
we could play some Tetris on here you
could see some essays and my sister
wrote three games games by brother
I'm brother oh my gosh no way she made a
full range of other folders as I wanted
to play games I didn't have a computer
so these are my games that I played gun
shy something called happy weed
I remember happy weed playing but I
don't I have no recollection so we did
one it ended up Mac man my sisters
Tetris and something called space junkie
so you steer the ship what would what
would you like okay apply on the power
book oh it's heavy oh why I waited Wow
hun Wow and there are little things
there too just like the height so the
keyboard felt more natural well really
I'm like it's old-school mechanical
keyboard like that is a keyboard feels
really good actually look how fat the
trashcan is no okay let's see what happy
wheat is oh that is so cool Wow like you
can hear it
The Adventures of happy week I mean it's
like a marijuana leaf it looking like I
don't think I knew what that was when I
was little I had no idea oh my god it is
I definitely played this I don't think I
had any concept that this was over I
remember this now this was drugs I
didn't know my whole entire life
wait know where this is no coulis must
have been to like a you know 12 year old
girl oh my god I don't even know how old
I would have been but I definitely
played this definitely had no concept of
there's new drugs the first time I swear
my channel is because of this game this
is incredible
Scotty monetizing me do you want to dive
I think this game was also free so that
was why I don't even quit it they have
force quit back then oh here it is
oh yeah dude look watch okay command
quit boom
so still like still war I'm shocked when
I booted this thing out that actually
worth so PowerBook 180 codename converse
the minimum OS was 7.1 the maximum was
seven point six point one introduced
October of 1992 and terminated May of
1994 single lasted it's a long time
their point to get update see they're
probably like here it is yeah any time
of those two years a power book 168 was
one of the first ones to have a video
port supporting an external 13 to 16
inch monitor I vaguely remember having a
monitor my parents house to have a
monitor I think is look at the IO in the
back like there's a ton so they had a
vid 14 connector that was apples
proprietary display only this ever went
online fully working fully functional
like you could still learn to write an
essay on here about this Macintosh let's
say probably the reason that I wanted to
become a graphic designer was because of
these backgrounds making those pixel
designs in the background
you take it your phones now have a like
64gb storage like 20 years from now you
think you only had 64 gigs of storage
built-in memory
total is 8190 and that was a big deal I
know the big deal
gosh and the trackball is kind of weird
it's strange and it's a good weird
designs that they had to put this big
like Ridge and then to the screens all
over you
backs that trackball didn't hit the
screen my gosh that makes a make sense
okay let's see what her touches okay
this is Meredith Tetris she renamed it
she was like this is not a mattress oh
my god okay so what same Tetris like
everybody builders how did you even get
it probably probably probably gotta be a
floppy what was it was compusa yeah they
were called us a store and he had the
whole like Mac section yes I remember
calling ID games as a kid once a week
asked them what you doing was coming out
like not yet yeah a number memorized I
would like to own my parents room
because it's kind of like yeah Point
Dume okay when is it coming out format
you'd be like I don't know kid my
favorite game well my favorite fighting
game was Mortal Kombat 2 and I remember
my parents never let me play it so I'm
go to my friend's house and play yeah
bro Kombat 2 and that was what that gave
me like a rippin skulls out like spines
planet people's heads is extremely bad
feel like cement when you're playing
games to like the violence aspect you
feel like you're completing a task kind
of disregard the violence when you're
playing oh yeah and also like tennis for
card to me to like think I know that
like you're not the god of thunder right
you're not Raiden maybe I am I am Molina
though space junkie do you want to give
it a go I don't know what this is either
is that the actual app or I think it's
in here Oh games my brother's failed us
we have the readme let's read about it I
used to hate those things and I would
never read them you gotta try typing on
this I feel like I knew okay see holy
it's so good it is very quiet yeah I am
okay how are you I just ask that it
feels great yeah and like the speakers
were surprisingly good on it can we play
a song on here this is before like
Winamp in that kind of stuff okay let's
go into the system folder we can play
some sounds if there was definitely a
sound folder you navigating this UI like
a pro I'm pretty impressive Nord and I'm
having a flashback
there's definitely a sounds thing in
here yes here it is yes under the boot
up sound the droplet something's are
still in like Mac OS yeah I'm getting a
little teary-eyed I'm so sorry like it
just it this is this is taking me back
to a time where I was a very small young
needle just everything can you do the
sound mm-hmm I spent a lot of time
practicing sounds hey let's go through
these one by one
what else is in these settings all the
labels this was so exciting all you
could do was a grayscale labels but I
thought that was so cool I can't believe
this still works first of all shot and
this is in really good condition worse
like perfectly yes this is crazy look at
this color there's no color
okay we have a sticker on it for quality
service called the Apple doctor should
we call him TV still works let's call
him I think that's a sign yeah that
really that says a lot right there the
Apple doctor who's no longer in business
general control let's see oh let's take
a look I'm gonna take a picture of this
in my lap this is great so I feel like
this seems like a good time to tell you
this has been sitting for you probably
know 15 years doing the thing and it's
probably gonna go back in a box and do
the thing I would rather it go to a good
home where somebody can love it would
you would you like to keep this 100%
serious all of my sister's essays though
on that would you keep it and would sit
in a box
I would love somebody that come back and
love it if you ever need it back my
Kindle where I live I
can't see a reason why we would oh my
gosh are you sure made me really happy
oh my gosh oh my gosh I'm so glad thank
you know what to say I'm gonna make a
new I'm probably gonna change desktop
you can do whatever it is it can be
yours you can do whatever you want with
it
like I said I've like had generally been
a fan for a long time and I know your
love of these and I can't omit in
somebody who would appreciate it like
more I'm sweating I would like use it I
would love if you would keep it oh my
gosh she has a point and then you have
to actually I have to meet your sister
and she can come over and she can do a
dramatic reading oh she's a she's a vet
like me yeah oh my gosh well now we need
to be friends because I always have
questions about my dog she's me like can
you tell this is not me this is the
desktop pattern that I'm gonna change
later I'm not gonna do it now because
I'm gonna work and I make it really nice
I'm gonna make it really nice for you
send me pictures yes thank you thank you
for listening everyone I come here oh my
gosh I was gonna say it to the end off
camera but I mean no we did it on camera
I'm so excited you don't understand look
in my eBay watchlist
like I've been watching this that's
crazy I think they're hard to find
well it's like a dress people on eBay
usually they send me something it's not
working and this isn't like a bigger
picture much good condition like oh oh
we're gonna investigate this further in
another video you guys be prepared to
close all the windows I can't believe
this works like this is crazy
have you ever need a back you know
worries I'm good okay okay can't speak
for what she wrote on here see there's a
couple women's studies and essays on
here oh my gosh this is so amazing
but I brought other stuff too I have
other wait wait do you remember the
scrapbook
it was like the copy and paste like you
could cause those his things I'm doing
you could you remember the map yeah you
could base things in here like this is
what you see in the doctor like classic
Steve Jobs and like
the early days of graphical user
interface like this was it this was it
in the puzzle oh I remember the puzzle I
got way too excited it's a slider puzzle
but you can move on oh my gosh okay okay
I could we could probably make a
seven-hour video about this but I'm more
oh this is all stuff and I mean this is
my very first computer I'm where my
parents let me put it in my room is like
a giant deal for me so I'm bringing this
out oh my gosh we got some disk drives
here but no I know there's that I think
if you believe so I think Drake said it
best startup in the bottom now we're
here over here thanks for the assist
here we go oh my god and I believe a
working oh we need to monitor apple 2e
and then there's a friend that I have
that I didn't bring it's an apple to see
never the monitor is sat on top of this
yes so remember you had to have the
power supply to make it work there with
the own ports and then actually the
power cord that goes with it and the
ribbon cables that made everything work
there's like a special monitor that you
had to use like a good green monitor
you'd hook it up to like a dot matrix
printer this is so I'm gonna find the
monitor for a next video we're gonna
hook this up yeah if I'm pretty sure
that this works you remember you like
pick this up yeah well they're dissing
here so aggressive like this is what
they call the [__] cuz the floppy
exactly wow I never moon Patrol
I don't remember moon Patrol or one in
the kitchen noticing him man this is so
awesome
so I made an eBay mistake because I was
just getting super excited about all the
old vintage office after I was finding I
think it was an apple to see that I saw
and it comes in an original box but it
didn't have a monitor so if you have a
monitor up you can make all of these
things work so awesome this is what
computers look like this is like the hot
computer can you believe it have just
like this the Pisan I like the signature
inside I don't think no it was only in
the it was the 1984 it was the out of 28
okay and the 512 and then the one
megabyte one that my parents had did not
have a different Jersey
it's only in the first year that was
Wozniak and jobs both right yeah so this
is some my old school Apple tech I
thought
you I thought you'd get a kick of people
kind of got her sir Oh Apple great I
know and I feel like gosh that's crazy
how things have changed so quickly
really if you think about it it is not
shocking 92 but that's so mean
considering how things have gone from
this to this TV just things like that
we started here this is where right now
what's the future it's gonna be so
exciting start from the bottom knowing
yeah yes thanks Jake you brought that in
revolutionary revolutionary lyrics so
thank you so much
and thank you for coming here can you
help me I'm gonna bring you more
old-school Apple techniques it's gonna
be great I've been thinking about doing
a series of having people come over to
bring their own tagging and like this is
I guess the first episode really so this
is exciting cutting-edge here which I
just Eve is oh my gosh well thank you
make sure you guys go check out his
channel I'll put links in description
also where you can check out the WBC
video that we shot lots of redic I'll be
double WDC I'll send some updates please
don't feel good we're having fun yeah I
guess at the end of the video now
[Music]